please welcome terry crews and rebecca
king cruz
[Applause]
what's up how you doing hi terry
all right how are you well
funny enough when we started um doing
blended
i remember uh we talked about a lot of
different titles actually and i was like
because blended really wasn't a thing
when we made our movie
and i was like trust me it'll be a thing
i don't know and
it is it's a common vernacular now i
myself
am about to blend with um my kids and
um my ex-husband and his new fiance
and i myself got divorced it destroyed
me it was
not what i wanted at all we had no
controversy
we had human error we weren't able to
make it work together
but there are a lot of people who look
at the reasons why
things work and don't work and you guys
have been so open
in stronger together which is a uniquely
only audiobook
so you know it's your voices rebecca
what did you
learn what did you feel like you put out
there what were your takeaways and what
do you want for other people when they
listen to this
well my desire in being a part of
telling this story
was one to empathize with couples who
faced challenges like ours because
we just discovered we weren't the only
ones
when you're in the middle of breaking up
over infidelity
you feel like you're the only person in
the world whose heart is bleeding all
over the carpet
and i discovered that i wasn't and i
discovered that
not only was this a common
incidence in marriage as well as many
other struggles
but that there was help for me
and there was help from my husband who
fell under the category
um of a sexual addiction first of all i
just want to stop and pause and say
when you feel like you are the only one
it like brought tears to my eyes because
i was like
it's true you do and
one of the only ways that you don't feel
alone
is having the bravery to talk about it
that's right right well i'll tell you
you know we all have
our girlfriends but sometimes friends
don't have the help you need and that's
why we got professional help
when we first hit this moment and i told
my husband he wasn't allowed to come
home anymore
he called some people that we love and
trust
who advised him to get help for himself
and
i got to say this just because you know
success is the warmest place to hide
especially for a man
um the male ego uh tends to be its own
animal and i had
plenty of people telling me i was fine
plenty of people telling me no man
you're great
in fact you know what now you're free
you can do whatever you want and you're
like
but you know what i i want my wife like
i realized
what i really needed in my life i
realized
that anything without her was nothing
and
i had right it's like the old joni
mitchell song you don't know what you
got to list gone
i said i said and you know hollywood
doesn't care if you lose your family
they just don't
um and i realized that i needed to
change
it was a really drastic move and you
gotta understand culturally especially
i came up in sports culture male culture
the whole thing is about
you know you don't change everything is
all right you you gotta
hold the port and keep the face and the
whole thing
i realized thank god i realized that the
issue was
me it had nothing to do with her anyone
else
it was me and i was shocked drew that he
humbled himself like that and when i
threw him out i meant it
it wasn't like a little game like i'm
gonna say
that we're done and then hope you follow
me out the door marriage was over
i was done what do you say to women who
have done that which it sounds like you
got to that point how did you come back
rebecca you know drew that's the
question i get asked more than anything
is why did i give him another chance
and a few it was probably a few weeks
later
i felt this strong same inner voice
saying to me
call him and talk to him and see where
he is right now
and by that point my husband had called
three counselors and two pastors
and had already checked himself into
rehab
and my husband so
beautifully began to own up to his own
problems
that he shocked me drew i'm telling you
the truth
i did not expect him to
go through what he went through to save
this family
you